recent economic data showed China's
economy is stabilizing even amid
persistent concerns about rising debt
Hong Kong's richest man li kai-shing
owns a wide array of assets in China
from ports to retail and energy I spoke
exclusively to li kai-shing in his first
interview with international media in
four years where he says he remains full
of optimism hey Jogi koto mo Toho
talking hinges on khakha Chicago Toa toy
a toy Apple ID he goes is like a niche
ano Cody my title evening football
Nipton koto you hold okay today so yo
soy yoga chill ago title okay which a
man can careful Jai tango utile ago de
Jong Coco Co Chico knock on door come on
Frida - hi
portable hi no way check out all your
power your sister like that don't mind
[ __ ] no longer go hold or cellular so in
a chilling like time some work angel
I mean ye but recently you faced
criticism from some publications in
mainland China accusing you of
diversifying away from China at a time
of slowing growth is this true yo yo yo
cha cha cha botany CM Punk don't oh yeah
Oh Jo yeah boy Koga KD yogic every
killer yo ha como yo ho Gianna
Tom Saddam's tongue soup and Chong Bo
say music simple boy clay sang why the
tree no don't see
I woke up from Vulcan Funko trajector
domum Orient I didn't know be haughty
conga conga aqua oh my god eje him a
Tomo gain knowledge of King dong dong ba
ba ha ha saw him what she come corner
like Jong Kook Tom Gable there are a lot
of Chinese companies who are looking
overseas to acquire businesses but they
keep getting shut down by regulators
including yourself what is the impact
for Chinese companies in the future how
do they fix this oh yeah you go you go
beg no muy go coca a chunk o ecto
motions and finding no coke Itachi moco
in co2 funding some gitaji ha Jesus
frustrating my modey modey gotcha game
toe bob and a moat ido EAGA nahi go Kaka
moto yellow Kaito Kaito jozani hecto yo
[ __ ] I hike whoa
sorry longing Akai what the hotel - yeah
um your son Shankar Coco Sangha hungry
my son gitaji a bomb attack piccata you
you tried yoga kappa yog architecture
team Joe notary watch EKG Sangeeta in
urine sample